welcome to Facebook and understands that
it's become very fashionable recent
years to smear the British Monarchy as
racist it's the age of white privilege
today's Royals must atoned the colonial
sins or at a touch Beyond reform they
should be abolished and embark on
endless groveling apology tour for the
terrible ancestors I find most of that
complete nonsense the monarchy is mostly
a reason for immense national pride they
represent us with distinction and
dignity to the world that's why when the
queen died the whole world stopped still
for 10 days to pay homage to her and
what she stood for
but there is a duty I think for everyone
at the Royal household from the top down
to be responsible about the positions
they hold and sometimes they let us down
last night Camilla the Queen the new
Queen hosted a reception on domestic
violence at Buckingham Palace well Lady
Susan Hussey Prince William's godmother
and was one of the Queen's closest Queen
Elizabeth's closest aides for many many
decades
made racially charged comments to the
head of a domestic abuse charity in gozi
Fulani the woman she spoke to released a
transcript of what she says it's a
conversation they had we've had it
voiced by producers
where are you from Sister space no where
do you come from We're based in Hackney
no what part of Africa are you from I
don't know they didn't leave any records
well you must know where you're from I
spent time in France where are you from
here UK no but what nationality are you
I'm born here and I'm British no but
where do you really come from where do
your people come from my people lady
what is this oh I can see I'm going to
have a challenge getting you to say
where you're from when did you first
come here lady I am a British national
my parents came here in the 50s when oh
I knew we'd get there in the end your
Caribbean no lady I'm of African
Heritage Caribbean descent and British
nationality
well let me be very clear those comments
in today's age I'm afraid are shocking
they crass they're offensive they're
racist that's why Lady Hussey is now
rightly resigned the palace says the
comments are unacceptable they've
quickly fronted up to this Scandal for
that they deserve credit this won't go
away in a hurry it will be Grist to the
mill for those who want to trash the
monarchy and Brandi a racist institution
the timing could hardly be worse next
week the Duke and Duchess of Sussex will
be ludicrously given a human rights
award for fighting racism in the royal
family it was Megan of course who
infamously smeared the monarchy's racist
in her Oprah Winfrey wineathon Megan has
never produced any evidence tandem the
conversation of he won't be given
security he's not going to be given a
title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
well Meg has ever given any hard
evidence to back up any of her racism
claims but mud sticks the damage was
done and this Scandal will undoubtedly
fuel those who think that there was
Merit to what she said
now what's been going on today by
coincidence is that Prince William and
the Princess of Wales have been in the
United States in Boston for a three-day
tour and that will now be completely
overshadowed by this new race storm back
in London I think that's why he took the
unusual step today of attacking lady
Hussey remember his own godmother
directly racism has no place in society
William spokesman said these comments
were unacceptable and it's right that
the individual stepped aside with
immediate effect that individual is his
own godmother
and make no mistake she wasn't a minor
background figure at the palace lady
Hussey was the late Queen's most loyal
lady and waiting for I think five or six
decades
she Stood Beside the new Queen Camilla
on state occasions and it will raise
uncomfortable questions about how
somebody in her position could possibly
be so stupid
after Megan's original baseless claims
Prince William said categorically the
royal family is not a racist family and
I believe him I also believe the
monarchy is a powerful unifying force in
our country but in this year of
transition with all eyes on King Charles
or the coronation coming
and inevitable questions about the
future of monarchy has to do better than
this
nobody capable of such witness and
offensive comments should be in the
Royal household and it's right lady
Hussey has gone
but there should also now be a fool I
think investigation to see if anybody
else in that household shares similar
sentiments and Views because if they do
they shouldn't be there well joining me
now is former BBC World correspondent
Michael Cole and the organizer of black
lives matter protests Imam ayton welcome
to both of you
someone said to me today look she's in
her 80s there is a generational aspect
to this where people of her age might
ask questions which sound wrong and I
can understand a little bit that that
might be the case and maybe it is a bit
generational it doesn't mean it's not
offensive or crass or frankly racist I
mean for a black woman to be invited to
the palace and be subjected to this
bizarre interrogation
persistently demanding to know where she
was from when she was born in this
country and is a British citizen is
completely outrageous and the most
terrible thing peers of course is that
the focus is now not on domestic
violence and eradication of that which
is most important it's on this incident
it's all terrible and it's very sad but
as you've said lazy Susan hussy is 83
she's a widow she was married to Mama
June custody who calls random BBC was
the chairman of the BBC indeed
well I've seen her around the world when
she was the head girl as you so rightly
say to her majesty the queen in all
sorts of uh situations with different
people from different backgrounds
different ethnicity and she was always
charming and very kind and very nice now
what we don't have
is a recording of that we have a
transcript of somebody's remembrance of
that conversation but we do know an
investigation was very quickly commenced
and we do know the result is she has
immediately been let go now exactly and
she apologized immediately so there's no
denial of it no no no there is none she
apologized and she's resigned and let's
be honest about it nobody actually died
nobody was killed on this occasion
it it is offensive it shouldn't have
happened and remedies have been taken
and I feel sorry for her I've got uh you
know I knew her quite well I never saw
her act other than properly she always
put people at ease what she didn't learn
is what the queen always learned when
she was in a situation like this with
people she didn't know she would always
say have you come far now that is a very
good question because nobody can take
all right let me go to Iman here look
Michael's putting a sort of nice gloss
on this but if I'm a black woman
and I've gone to the Palace particularly
for a charity event like that and I've
done so much good work as in gozi Fulani
has done with just sister space
organization and acne you know just for
those who don't know what it is it's a
group that supports African and
Caribbean women affected by domestic and
sexual abuse so
to be there and to be so belittled by a
very Posh older white lady who's been
working at the palace for six decades to
be belittled in that way and to be
constantly challenged about where you're
really from with all the racist
undertones of when you can't be one of
us you clearly come from somewhere else
I find that offensive and I'm a white
man
utterly offensive so I'm very glad that
you both agree
um so what this example is covert racism
so
um it's basically covert racism in the
form of a micro validation so when
someone comes along and says where are
you from no no no where you really from
what they're inferring is that that
person couldn't possibly as a black
woman have you had this experience oh
this is this is every day right racism
how does it make you feel when it
happens to you
utterly ignored I feel offended I feel
dismissed and I feel as if I've been put
into this kind of box where I'm not seen
nor am I heard and I'm just expected to
just go along with this kind of
narrative which is okay to perpetuate
racism throughout the day so for me
personally it's an experience that most
black people I can confidently say
experience on a day-to-day basis do you
give any slack to her age that it's a
generational thing that that generation
may not have even realized that asking
somebody questions like that is racist
um I take that into consideration but it
doesn't negate the fact that that seems
to stem throughout many generations and
therefore we cannot take away the fact
that covert racism is prevalent within
our society irrespective of your age
Michael what's extraordinary to me is
we've just been through the whole Megan
and Harry Oprah racism
thing there will be people there are
already on Twitter saying she's been
Vindicated this is what she was talking
about the subliminal racism that is
laced through the palace hard to argue
that now I would argue the difference is
here we had a name somebody did
something and the victim of this put a
tweet out using the initials sh and said
it was a lady it was only one of those
in the palace so we knew who she was
talking about and that person's been
made accountable my issue with Megan and
Harry from the start of their racism
claims is there's never been any hard
evidence put forward nor have they named
who they who they believe was racist
therefore everyone is Guilty By
Association so they are to me different
things but there is no doubt this will
lend sucker to their argument as they
stand on this stage at the Robert F
Kennedy Foundation next week for their
heroism in tackling racism at the palace
there's no doubt they will use this to
fuel their position and that's very much
why Buckingham Palace moved Swiss lastly
and Prince William moves swiftly to
distance himself for it really really
pretty amazing I mean they're pretty in
context that woman's his godmother yeah
yeah she was one of the Queen's closest
if not the closest Confidant of the
queen for 60 years absolutely this is
not just anyone at the back well as her
her godson can't stand up for her I'll
have to stand up for ladies Susan and
say that I'm sure there was no malice
intended everybody was wearing name pads
perhaps she saw the name which was of
course unusual to her and perhaps she
was genuinely trying to find out a
little bit about where she came from
it's quite a normal thing for people to
say have you come far have you been this
way around but I understand why the
palace you know racism is absolutely
toxic the terrible thing about the
charge of racism is it's easy to make
and it's almost impossible to really in
this case you see I think it's a clear
open and sharp case I mean I agree with
what you just said but I also think that
black people in this country will all
look at this incident everyone who is
black in this country will look at
what's happened here and they'll all be
able to cite similar instances where
people have said where are you from and
not really wanting to think they're
British like we white people and that is
the damaging thing about this episode is
that you've got somebody at the heart of
the palace for so long so close to the
queen so close to all of them William's
godmother right I mean that's where I
think if I'm in your position you know
representing a community looking at this
going yeah a we've all been through this
and B wow wow that's somebody quite
senior at Buckingham Palace doing it yes
and I think I have to add the fact that
it's a double kind of slap in the face
for a lot of black people because
ultimately this event took place where
Camilla Queen Camilla made a speech that
was focused on domestic violence and she
made it quite clear we need to firstly
she said that it was a heinous crime
secondly she said that we need to
support and listen to survivors and
thirdly we need to believe their stories
now racism is Justice heinous as
domestic violence right they manifest
themselves in more or less the exact
same way from ranging from psychological
to physical so the reality is that we
seem to have this uh notion of
supporting and believing and
understanding and listening to those of
domestic violence when it comes to black
people we end up gaslighting which is
basically another form of racism so we
find more racism let me throw a slice
let me throw a slight thing back at your
on that General principle I I have a
problem with believing everyone just
when they come forward with any
allegation it may be the cynical
journalist in me but I believe everyone
should be listened to everyone should be
taken seriously but they're not
automatically victims until something is
proven because a lot of people I'm
afraid in modern society they invent
stories they have reasons to scam you
know to Media whatever it may be for
whatever reason
and certainly percentage-wise probably
not a vast percentage but there are
people that will do it so I believe you
listen you take seriously you show
respect a claimant who's making
allegations but I don't think whether
it's racism or violence or whatever it
may be you don't automatically believe
people the moment you do that I
automatically condemning and convicting
the people they're accusing who have not
had a chance to put their case forward
and it may be the completeness but what
you first need to do is listen and
ultimately believe because this is why
it comes but do you agree with the sort
of principle I'm making that's what I do
it totally utterly agree with you but
what it comes down to is a fine line you
see because when you ultimately and I
said it the last time I was here when an
individual ignores negates or neglects
the thoughts feelings and experiences of
those from the black and brown Community
when pertaining to racism what you're
ultimately doing is invalidating their
experiences which is a form of racism
this is a typical thing that we see and
this is the issue that what I typically
find when it comes down to racism it is
a form of gaslighting that seems to be
the typical Let's ignore that but we're
not
I think this whole we've got into a
place in society now where people can
talk about my truth as if somehow that's
different to the truth and I've got a
big problem with that whoever it is
because to me there's the truth which is
supported by facts and if you have your
own version of it it's not actually the
truth I mean you can feel it and you can
want it to be true but actually facts
should always be sacred because
otherwise I'm not sure where you go if
everyone has their own version of the
truth but Michael it is it seems to me
there's an another bigger issue which
I'm about to come through with another
guest in a minute
we now have William and Kate in Boston
for three days this is supposed to be
the big coming out of the new Prince and
Princess of Wales in America you've got
Megan and Harry in California about to
go to New York to receive this Robert F
Kennedy Foundation which I think is
ludicrous for their heroism in combating
racism at the palace that's not why they
left they left because they wanted to do
their own thing and the Royal cake and
eat it and make gazillions at Netflix we
all know that documentary is coming out
very soon and we'll all see it as is the
book and you've chosen to ignore exactly
what she said about her experiences
thoughts and feelings no no I'll just
throw that in okay
you can say that yeah
I will refer The Honorable lady to the
answer I gave some moments ago which was
actually she needs to come out they both
do and say who it was that expressed the
concern about the skin color of their
child I agree because the other
allegation they made that Archie was not
a prince because of his skin color was
very quickly discounted they just got
that wrong it doesn't have to do with
his skin color every everything to do
with the order that things go in in the
palace so it's only down to that one
charge left which is that someone in the
royal family expressed concern about the
skin color of their child and she said
it happened at a certain time Harry then
said it happened a year and a half
earlier they couldn't even work out what
year it happened and we've never had a
name unlike kids because you think they
haven't because it's out of respect the
same respected yeah
and that's why they won't they must
slowly give out that I think they've
shown unbelievable disrespect for the
role because of stating they have a few
experience
that's disrespectful they've milked
their attacks on the royal family to the
tune
I'm genuinely curious because you're
saying milk and so all of these things
again I'm just throwing it back at you
what you're what it appears to be is you
are ultimately gaslighting Megan and
Harris yes
I'm asking I'm responding I'm directly
calling them out I'm saying that they
are they what they've done they have
taken their role titles from an
institution they profess to dislike
they've taken them to America and they
are fleecing them for massive personal
commercial gain I think it's completely
yeah I think it's completely outrageous
self-awareness self-awareness yes
and racial Prejudice institutions